fall guys is dominating the playstation
plus world right now
but there's another pair of games coming
soon if you are a ps plus subscriber and
want to know what you can grab for free
in september
i've got you covered here's the new
lineup
just like august's freebie fall guys the
first free game is also a battle royale
player unknown's battlegrounds pubg is
basically responsible for the current
battle royale craze
dropping 100 players onto the map to
battle it out to be the last person
or squad standing it's got guns and
gears to loot
vehicles to drive and lots of intense
moments
the second ps plus game is also for the
competitive crowd
street fighter v this entry introduced
the v-gauge
letting you pull off special attacks and
reversals it also gave us the awesome
tornado fighter rasheed
the game's final season of dlc
characters is kicking off soon
so it's a great time to jump in and
those are your free playstation plus
games for september
they'll be available from september 1st
through october 5th
remember that you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on gamespot
and stay tuned as we report on the new
ps plus lineup every month
[Music]
you